it's become a big topic actually
thinking about the connection between
consciousness and
morality david chalmers the philosopher
is most associated with this concept of
a a philosophical zombie
so a philosophical zombies
very different from a hollywood zombie
hollywood zombies you know
you know what they're like but
philosophical zombies are it's a really
good uh korean zombie movie on halloween
this year come over it's called anyway
uh
uh philosophical zombies behave just
like us because the the physical
workings of their body and brain are the
same as ours but they have no conscious
experience there's nothing that it's
like to be a zombie so you stick a knife
in it it screams and run away but runs
away but it doesn't actually
feel pain it's just a complicated
um
mechanism
set up to behave just like us now
there's lots of no one believes in these
i think there's one philosopher who
believes in
everyone is a zombie except him but
anyway but isn't that what illusionism
is is blue yeah everybody's i suppose i
suppose so in a sense illusionism as if
you were all zombies and you know one
one
reason to think about zombies is to
think about the value of consciousness
so if there were a zombie here's a
question
suppose suppose we could i mean suppose
we could make zombies by let's say for
the sake of discussion
things made of silicon aren't conscious
i don't know if that's true it could
turn out to be true and suppose you
built
commander data out of silicon you know
it's a bit of an old-school reference to
star trek next generation so you know
behaves just like a human being but
you know it can you can have a
sophisticated conversation it will talk
about its hopes and fears but it has no
consciousness does it have moral rights
um
is it
murder to turn off such a being you know
i'm inclined to say
no it's not you know if it doesn't have
experience it doesn't really suffer it
doesn't really have moral rights at all
so i'm inclined to think you know
consciousness
is the basis
of
moral value moral concern
and conversely as as a as a pancychist
for this reason i think it can transform
your relationship with nature if you
think of a
tree as
a conscious organism albeit of a very
unusual kind
then a tree is a
locus of
moral concern in its own right chopping
down a tree is an act of immediate moral
concern if you see these
you know horrible
forest fires
we're all horrified but if you think
it's the burning of conscious organisms
that does add
a whole new dimension although it also
makes things more complicated because
people often think as a pan cyclist i'm
going to be
vegan but
it's tricky because if you think plants
and trees are conscious as well you've
got to eat something if you if you don't
think plants and trees are conscious
then you've got a nice moral dividing
line you can say i'm not going to eat
things that aren't conscious i'm not
going to kill things unconscious
but if you think
plants and trees are conscious then
you don't have that nice moral dividing
line i mean so the the principle i'm
kind of
working my way towards i haven't kept it
up in in my trip to the us but
it's just
not eating any animal products that are
factory farmed
you know my vegan friends say well are
still suffering there and i think there
is even in the even in the um
the nicest farms
cows will suffer when their cows when
their calves are taken off them they go
for a few days of quite serious morning
so they're still suffering but it seems
to me
my thought is
the principle
of just not having factory farm stuff is
something more people could get on board
with and you might have greater harm
minimization so if people went into
restaurants and said
are your animal products factory farmed
if not i want the vegan option or if
people looked out for the label that
said no factory farmed ingredients you
know i think maybe that could make a
really big difference to the market and
harm minimization anyway so that's the
so it's very ethically tricky but um but
some people don't buy that there's a
very good philosopher jeff lee who
thinks zombie should have equal rights
consciousness
it doesn't matter you know yeah
let us go there
but first
uh i listen to your podcast it's awesome
to have two very kind of different
philosophies inter uh dancing together
in one place uh what's the name of the
podcast again mind chat yeah so yeah
that's the idea i guess you know
polarized times i mean i i love
trying to get in the mindset of people i
really disagree with and you know i
can't understand
how on earth they're thinking that you
know really trying to have respect and
try and you know see where they're
coming from i love that so that's what
yeah keith frankish and i do of
from polar opposite views
really trying to understand each other
and you know interviewing scientists and
philosophers of consciousness from those
different perspectives although in in a
sense
in a sense
we we have a very common a common
starting point because we both think
you can't
fully account for consciousness at least
as philosophers normally think of it in
conventional scientific terms so we
serve that starting point
but we we react to it in very different
ways he says well it doesn't exist then
it's like furry dust it's you know
witches you know we don't believe in it
anymore as i say
it does exist so we have to find them we
have to rethink what science is so you
recently talked to on that podcast with
sean carroll and i first heard you
uh your um
great interview with sean carroll on his
podcast
mindscape
what uh it's interesting to kind of uh
see if there's agreements
disagreements
between the two of you because he's a
he's a you know a very serious quantum
mechanics guy he's a physics guy but he
also thinks about deep philosophical
questions
he's a big proponents of uh many walls
interpretation of quantum mechanics
so
actually i'm trying to think
um aside from your conversation with him
i'm trying to i'm trying to remember
what he thinks about consciousness but
anyway maybe you can comment on what uh
what are some interesting agreements and
disagreements with sean carroll
i don't think there's many agreements
but
but you know we've had really
constructive interesting discussions in
in it in a lot of different contexts and
um you know he's very clued up about
philosophy he's very respectful of
philosophy certain physicists who shall
remain nameless think what's all this
[ __ ] philosophy we don't have to
waste our time with that and then go on
to do pretty bad philosophy
um the book co-written by stephen
hawking and leonard malodnov famously
starts off saying philosophy is dead
and then goes on in later chapters to do
some
pretty bad philosophy so
i think we have to do philosophy
if only to get rid of bad philosophy you
know you can't you can't escape but um
strong words sean carroll and i also
had a debate on on clubhouse a pan
psychism debate together with annika
harris and owen fleming oh wow
there was a
two people on each team and uh i missed
it it was the most popular thing on
clubhouse
at that time
um
so
yeah so he's a he's a
a materialist
of a pretty standard kind
that um consciousness is being
understood as a sort of emergent feature
it's not not adding anything a weekly
emergent feature
but what i i guess what we've been
debating most about is is whether
my view can account for mental causation
for the fact that consciousness is doing
stuff
so he thinks the fact that
i think zombies are logically coherent
it's logic there's a it's logically
coherent
for there to be a world physically just
like ours
in which there's no consciousness
he thinks that shows oh my view
consciousness doesn't do anything it
doesn't add anything
which is crazy you know my my
my consciousness impacts on the world my
conscious thoughts are causing me to say
the words i'm saying now my visual
experience helps me navigate the world
but
i mean my response to sean carroll is is
on the panzerkist view the relationship
between
physics
and
fundamental consciousness
is is a sort of like the relationship
between software and hardware right
uh
physics is sort of the software and
consciousness is the hardware
so um
consciousness at the fundamental level
is the hardware on which the software of
physics runs um
and just because you know
just because a certain bit of software
could run on two different kinds of
hardware it doesn't mean the hardware
isn't doing anything the fact that
microsoft word can run on your desktop
and run on your laptop doesn't mean your
desktop isn't doing anything similarly
just because
there could be another universe in which
the physics is realized in non-conscious
stuff
it doesn't mean the consciousness in our
universe
isn't doing stuff you know for the pan
cyclist all there is is consciousness so
if something's doing something it is
in your view it's not emergent
and uh
more than that it's doing quite a lot
it's doing everything it's the only
thing that exists yeah but it's what so
you know
the ground
is
as important because we walk on it it's
like holding stuff up but it's not
really doing that much
yeah
but it feels like consciousness is doing
quite a lot it's doing quite a lot of
work
and
sort of interacting with the environment
it feels like consciousness is not just
a
like
if you remove consciousness it's not
just that you remove
the experience of things it feels like
you're also going to remove a lot of the
progress of human civilization in
society and and all of that it just
feels like consciousness has a lot of
value in how we develop our society so
from everything you said with suffering
with morality yeah with motivation
with
love and fear and all of those kinds of
things it seems like it's it's uh
consciousness in all different flavors
and ways is part of all of that
and so without it
you're you may not have uh human
civilization at all
so it's doing a lot of work because
causality causality-wise and
in every kind of way of course when you
go to the physics level it starts to say
okay
how much
maybe the work consciousness is doing
is uh higher at some levels of reality
than others
maybe a lot of the work it's doing is
most apparent at the human level when
you have at the complex organism level
maybe it's quite boring like maybe this
the stuff of uh like physics is more
important at the formation of uh
at this formation of stars and all that
kind of stuff consciousness only starts
being important when you have greater
complexities of uh
of organism yeah my consciousness is
complicated and fairly complicated
and
i as a result it does complicated things
the consciousness of a particle is
very simple and hence it really behaves
in predictable ways but but the idea is
the con the particle
its entire nature is
constituted of its forms of
consciousness and it does what it does
because of those experiences it's just
that when we when we do physics we're
not interested in what stuff is we're
just interested in what it does so
physics abstracts away from the stuff of
the world and just
describes it
into
in terms of its mathematical causal
structure
so
yeah but it's still on the panzerkiss
consciousness that's doing stuff yeah
i gotta ask you
because you kind of said you know
there is some value
um
in consciousness helping us understand
morality and
a philosophical zombie
is
somebody that
you know
you're
more okay how do i phrase it that's not
like
accusing you of stuff
but
in your view
it's more okay to murder a philosophical
zombie than it is a human being
yeah i wouldn't even call it murder
maybe but you're right exactly turn off
the power
into the philosophical zombie the source
of energy
yeah so here comes then the question
we kind of talked about this offline a
little bit
so i think that there is something
special about consciousness
and you know
very open-minded about where
the special comes from whether it's the
fundamental base of all reality uh like
you're describing or whether there's
some
importance to the special pockets of
consciousness that's in humans or living
organisms
i'm told i find all those ideas
beautiful and exciting
and i also
know or think
that robots don't have
consciousness in the same way we've been
describing
sort of i'm
i'm kind of a dumb human but i'm just
using like
common sense
like here's some metal and some
electricity traveling certain kinds of
ways i don't it's not conscious
um in in ways i understand humans to be
conscious
at the same time i'm also a
somebody who knows how to bring a robot
to life meaning i can make a move i can
make him recognize the world i can make
him interact with with humans and when i
make him interact in certain kinds of
ways
i as a human observe them and and feel
something for them
uh moreover
i
form a a kind of connection with i'm
able to form a kind of connection with
robots
that make me feel like they're conscious
now i know intellectually they're not
conscious but i feel like they're
conscious and it starts to get into this
area where
i'm not so okay so let me use the m word
of murder i'm i've become less and less
okay
murdering
that robot
that i know
i quote know is quote
not conscious
so like can you maybe as a therapy
session and help me figure out what we
do here
and and perhaps a way to ask that in
another way do you think there'll be a
time in like 20 30 50 years
when we're not morally okay
um turning off the power to a robot
yeah it's a good question so it's a
really good important question i
so i said i'd be okay with
turning off a philosophical zombie
but
there's a difficult
epistemological question there that
meaning you know to do with knowledge
how would we know if it was a
philosophical i think probably if there
were
a silicon
creature that could behave
just like us and
you know talk about its views about the
pandemic and the global economy and
probably we would think it's conscious
um
and it you know it
it because consciousness is not publicly
observable it is a very difficult
question how we decide which things are
and are not conscious and so in the case
of human beings
we can't observe their consciousness but
we can ask them and then we try to you
know and we if we scan their brain while
we do that and or stimulate
the brain then we can start to correlate
in the human case which kind of brain
activity are associated with conscious
experience
but the more we depart from the human
case
the trickier that becomes
uh
famous paper by uh the philosopher ned
block called the even harder problem of
consciousness
where he says you know
could we ever answer the question of
um so suppose you have a silicon
duplicate right
and let's say we're thinking about
the silicon duplicates pain
um
how would we ever know whether what's
the ground of the pain
is
the hardware or the software really so
in our case how would we ever know
empirically whether it's the specific
neurophysiological state
see fibers firing or whatever that's
relevant for pain or if it's something
more functional more to do with uh the
ro the causal role in behavioral
functioning that's the software that
that's realized
and and
that's important because
this silicon duplicate
has the second thing it has the software
it has the
the thing that plays the relevant causal
role that pain does in us but it doesn't
have the heart where it doesn't have the
same neurophysiological state and he
argues you know it's it's just really
difficult to see how we'd ever answer
that question because in a human you
inevitably can have both things so how
do how do we work out which is which and
i mean so even in even forgetting the
hard problem of consciousness
even the scientific question of trying
to find the neural correlates of
consciousness is is really
hard and there's absolutely no consensus
and you know so that some people think
it's in the front of the brain some
people think it's in the back of the
brain
it's just a total mess so
i suspect the robots you currently have
are not conscious
um i guess on any of the reasonably
viable models even though there's great
disagreement
all of them probably would hold that
your robots are not conscious but you
know if if we could have very
sophisticated robots
um i mean if we go for example for the
integrated information theory again
there could be a
a robot set up to behave just like us
and has the kind of information a human
brain has
but the information is not stored in a
way that's involves is dependent on the
integration and interconnectedness then
according to the integrated information
theory that thing wouldn't be conscious
even though it behaved just like us if
an organism says
so forget iit and these theories are
cautious
if an organism says
please don't kill me
please don't turn me off
uh there's a rick and morty episode i've
been getting into that recently
that's fantastic uh there's a episode
where
there's these mind parasites
that
are able to infiltrate your memory and
inject themselves into your memory so
you have all these people show up in
your life
and they've injected themselves into
your memory that you have been part they
have been part of your life
so there's like these weird creatures
and they're like remember we've been at
that barbie we met at that barbecue or
we've been dating for the last 20 years
and so
part of me is concerned
that these philosophical zombies
in behavioral
psychological sociological ways will be
able to implant themselves into these
our society and convince us in the same
way this is my parasites that
like please don't hurt me and like we've
known each other for all this time like
they can start
manipulating you the same way like
facebook algorithms manipu at first
they'll start as a gradual thing that we
just you know you want to make a more
pleasant experience all those kinds of
things and it'll drift into that
direction that's something i think about
deeply because i i want to create these
kinds of systems but in a way that
doesn't manipulate people i want it to
be a thing that brings out the best in
people
without manipulation so uh it's always
human centric always human first but i
am concerned about that at the same time
i'm concerned about calling the other
it's the group thing that we mentioned
earlier in the conversation
some other group
the philosophical zombie like you're not
conscious i'm conscious you're not
conscious therefore it's okay if you die
i think that's probably that kind of
reasoning is what leaded to most
uh the the rich
history of genocide that i've been
recently studying a lot of
that kind of thinking so
it's such a tense aspect of morality
do we want to let everybody into our
circle of empathy our club
or do we want to let nobody in
um it's it's a it's a interesting dance
but i kind of lean towards empathy and
compassion
i mean what would be nice
if it turned out that
consciousness
was what we call strongly emergent that
it was associated with
new causal dynamics in the brain that
were not reducible to underlying
chemistry and physics this is another
ongoing debate i have with sean carroll
about whether current physics should
make us very confident that that that
that's not the case that there aren't
any strongly emerging causal dynamics i
don't think that's right i don't think
we know enough about brains to know one
way or the other if it turned out
that consciousness was associated with
these irreducible causal dynamics a that
would really help the science of
consciousness we've got these debates
about whether consciousness is in the
front of the brain or the back of the
brain it turns out that there are
strongly emerging causal dynamics in the
front of the brain that would be a big
piece of evidence but also it would help
us see which things
are conscious and which things aren't so
we can say
i mean i guess that's sort of the other
side of the same point we could say look
these zombies they're just they're just
mechanisms that are just doing what
they're programmed to do through the
underlying physics and chemistry whereas
look these these other people whether
they have these new causal dynamics that
emerge that go beyond
the um
the the base level physics and chemistry
i think the series west world where
you've got these theme parks with these
kind of
humanoid creatures they seem to have
that idea that the ones that became
conscious sort of rebel against their
programming or something i mean that's a
little bit
far-fetched but
that would be that would be really
reassuring if it was just you could
clearly mark out the conscious things
through these emerging causal dynamics
but that might not turn out to be the
case a pan cyclist doesn't have to think
that they could think everything's just
reducible to physics and chemistry and
then
i i still think i want to say
zombies don't have moral rights but how
we answer the question of who are the
zombies and who aren't i
i just got no idea if i just look at the
history of human civilization
the difference between a zombie and
non-zombie
is the zombie accepts their role as the
zombie
and willingly marches
to slaughter
and
the moment you stop being a zombie is
when you say no
is when you resist
because the reality is philosophically
is we can't know who's a zombie or not
and uh we just keep letting everybody in
who protests loudly enough he says i
refuse
to be slaughtered
like my people the zombies have been
slaughtered too long
we will not stand against the man
and uh we need a revolution that's the
history of human civilization one group
says
we're we're awesome you're the zombies
you must die and then eventually the
zombies say nope
we're done with this this is immoral
and so i just
i i think that's not a sorry that's not
a philosophical statement that's sort of
a practical statement of history is a
feature
of non-zombies
defined empirically
they say
we refuse to be called zombies any
longer we could end up with a zombie
proletariat you know if we can get these
things that do all our manual labor for
us you know they might start
forming trade unions i will lead you
against these humans
zombie
revolutionary leaders the zombie martin
luther king saying you know i have a
dream that my zombie children will but
look i mean we need to sharply
distinguish the ontological question
that's pointing to the camera talking to
the uh talking
people
the zombies
uh i mean maybe that's you know maybe
these illusionists maybe they are
zombies and the rest of us are maybe
there's just a difference but maybe
you're the only non-zombie yeah maybe
that's true i often suspect that
actually
i don't really uh i don't have such
delusions of grandeur
at least i don't admit to them um but i
just we've got to distinguish the
ontological question from the
epistemological question right in terms
of the reality of the situation
i you know there must be in my view a
fact of the matter as to whether
something's conscious or not and to me
it has rights if it's conscious it
doesn't if it's not
but then the epistemological question
how the hell do we know
um
it's a minefield but we'll have to sort
of try and cross that bridge when we get
to it i think
you